hi there steve kaufman uh here and today
i want to talk about
learning two languages at the same time
now i think some years ago i did a video
on the subject and i think my position
has always been that learning a language
requires so much dedication
that you kind of need to focus on one
and i suggested too that if you're far
enough along in one language you might
then devote 20 of your time
to another language or vice versa but
there is this 80 20 you still need to
focus on one language
certainly i remember when i was learning
chinese it was a total obsession i was
spending six seven hours a day on
chinese um
you know i would sort of steal time away
from my chinese to go and play tennis or
watch a movie but then rush back to my
chinese i was totally obsessed and
within one year i got to where i could
read novels and
and interpret and function in chinese
in my russian again i only focused on
the one language i was only putting in
an hour or so a day but i was doing it
over several years now
on my own but still focused on one
language and i have tended to focus on
one language but
you know i always stress that language
learning is a matter of what your goals
are what your preferences are your
situation and so forth so
i have now decided effective this
weekend i started in on farsi
i am not
far enough along really in arabic
uh
i'm going to soon i'm going to start
speaking with tutors in arabic and i'm
going to be doing it here at link
because hopefully this week we will
launch our new
platform making it easier for people to
be tutors at lincoln for people to find
tutors at link and i'm going to take
advantage of that to speak arabic and
you'll be able to just
judge my progress in arabic
uh but
i live in vancouver
and here particularly in north vancouver
there are a lot of farsi speakers
so i don't have much opportunity to use
arabic
but i do have opportunity to use farsi
so i said you know i want to start
getting into farsi first of all having
put a lot of effort into the arabic
writing system this is not going to help
me in farsi there's a few additional or
different letters in farsi but by and
large it's the same writing system
uh i want to be able to my doctor is
from iran uh shopkeepers are from iran
uh i run into farsi speakers all the
time
so
you know obviously this becomes
motivating and i often make the point
that you know how early you start to
speak depends on where you are and what
your opportunities are to speak uh if i
had been living in an arabic country for
example i would have spoken much more
arabic even with my limited level of
arabic
whereas you know having to set up
discussions via skype and stuff i want
to make sure that i have a certain level
you know of comprehension before i do
that i think i'm kind of starting to be
at that level now in my arabic
but
bear in mind that i'm retired i do
whatever i want with my time
i can putt around the garden i can go
play golf i last night we had the family
over we were swimming in the ocean
and within that i find time to indulge
my interest in languages
and an interest in languages means an
interest obviously in speaking to the
people but also connecting to that
history culture civilization and so
forth so obviously getting into arabic i
looked around and found that in my
library of books that i have bought over
time i have a book here on a history of
the arab peoples
which is interesting
and as i started into farsi then i
looked around my library again and i
found i had this book persian fire i
haven't gone very far into it
you know i tend to buy books because the
title seems interesting but it is as you
get into this book for example and and i
did and i read a bit about
uh you know cyrus
and the uh coruscant highway and and
just the extent to which
this the sort of middle east central
asia is connected
uh i mean the sort of
abrahamic religions you know
judaism christianity islam
came from a part of the world where
uh this is well before islam
where persians and semitic peoples
were and so you have the assyrians and
the
medians or whatever they were the medes
and the persians and
whatever it's all fascinating to read
about this but get a better sense of the
of the history and the geography of that
region
than you do just by you know looking at
the odd map of the world and so to me
that's fascinating and
i'm not yet we're at the level where i
could
you know read about the history of
arab
countries or
persia in their language but i'm kind of
starting on that journey and i find that
a very you know fascinating
prospect
that i can do that we have added i have
found people online to create content
for us in farsi we now have uh who is
she
which have started into we have the many
stories in farsi
we have a couple who are producing
casual conversation both at a beginner
level and a more sort of intermediate
level
all of this is gradually
going to be put up on link the only
problem with
with uh farsi is that we don't have
text-to-speech for whatever reason it's
not available in the text-to-speech
package that we use
so it's a bit of a disadvantage but what
i'm doing with farsi
you know i first have to start to get a
sense of the language so i'm going
through who is she and many stories i'm
doing it in sentence mode
and you can find sentence mode and by
the way this week
there'll be some changes to the site
that make it easier for people to find
sentence mode but with a new language
like farsi at first it's just noise to
me
uh and then i so i take it one sentence
at a time i listen over and over again
to that sentence i try to read it
i
go through like the first uh or a couple
of lessons in who she
start to see how the language works i
also have some books that i bought
living language but they're not that
helpful
um i can't absorb sort of verb
conjugations right up front uh so i
prefer to just kind of listen read
listen to it again
get a sense of how the language works
and that's basically where i am
after one day with farsi sort of just
discovering the language but i remember
that that's where i was with arabic
and we just had the the fellow that i
one of the people i'm i'm dealing with
in terms of getting more arabic content
for link is producing with a female
voice who is she
a very nice pleasant clear version of
who is she in arabic and he sent that
through and i listen to it and i
understand it all
so and yet when i started with arabic it
was just noise
so so when we start in a language
it's just noise and gradually we start
to observe the language start to look up
some words read it again
kind of understand it of course with
content like who is she the translation
is available there uh into english so i
can again see what that sentence means
in terms of a full sentence translated
uh and so you know i'm going to spend i
don't know how much time on on farsi but
obviously i'm i'm quite motivated to be
able to say a few things to farsi
speakers here in north vancouver but at
the same time we have some wonderful
content uh in arabic that's been
uploaded uh this
person from egypt to ahmed has a blog
and he talks about uh different uh you
know there's some biographies of famous
islamic scholars and so forth and so on
one of the interesting things by the way
i like little bits of
uh
serendipity or whatever it is
uh in the biography of al-biruni
who is a
basically a
persian
scholar who wrote in arabic
um
[Music]
a greek man is referred to as
el unani
it's the word for greek and i discover
from reading persian fire that the
persians refer to the greeks as
uhanians the ioannian sea uranian sea
however you pronounce that younani so
it's interesting to know
where this term presumably common in the
middle east four greeks come from it's
the ionian sea so
just to let you know that i'm exploring
two languages i'm going to keep them
apart
the arabic helps my
persian or farsi because there are some
identifiable arabic words in pharisee
plus the writing system is is very very
close
and but if i were going for an exam if i
had needed the language for my work i
would simply focus on one language but
i'm in a position where i can afford to
be a dilettante so there you have it on
learning two languages at the same time
in this case arabic and now farsi we'll
see how far i get
thank you for listening bye for now
[Music]
you